tensions are rising between the two
biggest economies china had warned the
us against house of representatives
speaker nancy pelosi's trip to taiwan
but on tuesday that's precisely where
she landed beijing views taiwan as a
breakaway chinese province and opposes
international recognition of its
government and visits from officials
military tensions along the taiwan
strait are high but pelosi says her trip
is a show of support for taiwan's
democracy
nancy pelosi's surprise visit to taiwan
threatens to throw off course
washington's fine balancing act neither
affirming nor denying beijing's claim to
the territory u.s and chinese stocks
sank on the news of pelosi's intention
to visit investors worry it could
inflame tensions between the two powers
stability in taiwan is important for
global supply chains
taiwan holds 20 percent of global
computer chip manufacturing capacity
it's the leader while the likes of china
the us and europe lag far behind and
look what happens when we focus on the
most complex and powerful chips those
under 10 nanometers taiwan is by far the
most dominant trailing far behind is the
only other country making such complex
chips south korea
the manufacturing of these chips is so
complicated that the production
processes are extraordinarily hard for
other countries to copy
taiwan's tech industry has helped it
become rich with a gdp per capita of
over 68 000
more than three times higher than
china's with its large but mostly poor
population
from the wall street journal but the
island's long-term future under china's
shadow is uncertain beijing sees the
visit as a provocation so investors and
security experts alike are alert to
anything that could tip the balance in
the china taiwan rivalry
for more let's bring in joyce lee in
taipei
what are the immediate local economic
consequences of nancy pelosi's visit
so china has a long history of punishing
other countries by cutting them off from
its market following pelosi's visit
china beijing has suspended imports of
more than 2 000 food products from
taiwan including tea honey and seafood
products in the past china hit single
products from the primary sector such as
a specific fruit or fish but this time
they're targeting processed foods too
the potential damage could be sizeable
china is taiwan's largest trading
partner with bilateral trade of over uh
300 billion dollars last year and keep
in mind that taiwan is holding a local
election in november uh where photos
typically focus on local economic and
social issues
so uh china's ban could weaken taiwan's
ruling party dpp in the coming election
and joyce just explained to our viewers
globally where taiwan fits in
taiwan's gdp ranks six in asia and uh
taiwan's tsmc produces more than 90 of
the world's advanced uh semiconductors
if you need a microchip to power your
phone or missile defense system you're
going to get it from taiwan even if
you're
china or the us so taiwan has made
itself uh indispensable to both sides
so
tell me more about the chip industry
because i know the us is pushing to
become more independent from taiwan uh
china
too has its eyes set on that uh chip
making industry it's very lucrative and
essential to so many different sectors
where would that leave taiwan if both
the us and china two of its biggest
customers
become more independent
well china has attempted to develop its
own semiconductors but they simply don't
have the knowledge about the delicate
process of chip making
meanwhile making chips in the u.s is
just too expensive so taiwan's top
officials had said that there is zero
chance that the semiconductor industry
could be hollowed out
and relocated to the u.s so for now
taiwan is irreplaceable
you heard it from joyce lee thank you
very much for filling us in with the
latest there from taipei